hi there my name is Michael del Castillo
senior editor of Forbes in charge of our
blockchain and cryptocurrency coverage
talking to you today about a report that
came out earlier this month by the Rand
Institute taking a closer look at some
more research done by Stanford that
could impact billions of people very
soon basically what happened is that
these Stanford researchers found that
you could use artificial intelligence to
create deep fakes or videos that look
like real videos interspersing 40
percent of somebody else's facial
features into your features and you
would barely even know in other words
they could make the person that you were
listening to look a little bit like you
as a way to gain your trust now what
happened was the these Rand researchers
taking a look at this Stanford Insight
had postulated that somebody like
Facebook that is building a so-called
metaverse or virtual reality layer of
the internet could create an environment
where a single person could address a
crowd of people and every single one of
those people would be looking at a
slightly different version of the
speaker in particular a virgin that had
been modified to make them seem more
trustworthy now it doesn't take a genius
to sort of see how this minor
technological accomplishment could could
reap giant rewards for manufacturers
politicians and many other people that
were trying to gain trust from the
audience as you can probably imagine not
everybody trusts the parent company of
Facebook to make the right decision here
after all Facebook has been blamed for
uh influencing perhaps untowardly
multiple elections and has been come
known for selling our personally
identifiable information to the highest
bidder in an effort to further companies
marketing schemes so a bunch of
non-profits have got together completely
separate from Facebook and and set out
to attack problems like this and this
problem itself head on there's one that
I recently had a chance to speak to
called project origin which is looking
to prove that information actually came
from where it alleges to be from and
importantly that that information got to
us unchanged so how does this fit into
this whole deep fake problem you can
imagine a world where you you take a an
actual video and a fake video and run
some computer analysis to compare which
one is real now this technology exists
and it works at its best about 65
percent of the time but the catch is the
ability to make the fakes is improving
at a faster rate of the ability than to
detect The Fakes so this non-profit
organization project origin set out to
tackle the problem a different way in
fact what they've done is they've
created a way using software to prove
that a video actually came from where it
appears to have come from and that it
came to us unchanged this could have
far-reaching implications not only in
the new space but other areas such as
video technology in the process of
building its technology project origin
discovered a number of other similar
efforts but in areas other than news for
example jpeg images videos
Etc and in order to ensure that there
was as little overlap as possible with
these different efforts and perhaps more
importantly that the technology
interoperated they got together with
these creators and created the Coalition
for Content provenance and authenticity
now some of the biggest companies in the
world are behind this the idea is that
these Solutions can be built by
non-profits these Solutions can be built
outside of the oversight of these big
tech companies and then it's just a
question of are these big tech companies
going to do the right thing the
immediate application that we're
interested in because of the round
report is in the area of deep fake
technology but it's actually uh could
apply to the entire burgeoning metaverse
space the metaverse you know has many a
wildly different definitions but I like
to think of it as a virtual reality
layer of the internet instead of going
and typing in a URL you could go visit
an actual location and what amounts to
an elaborate video game this space has
been forecast to be worth five trillion
dollars by 2030. The Venture Capital
raised in metaverse space in the first
half of 2022 is already double of that
was raised last year according to
research firm McKenzie it's about more
than just the moral thing to do or the
right thing to do it's a business
decision these problems have to be
solved and for those of you that don't
want to trust big Tech to do that these
non-profits out there are trying to
create solutions to if not force these
big tech companies to adopt them at
least make it so that they have the
option